es ist sehr schön jetzt habe ich morphin
alkohol wein und haschisch und jetzt
kommt noch bücher die von rausch handeln
habe ich ja wahnsinnig gerne ich weiß
und ich nicht so ich finde es ist ein
literarischer anfängerfehler zu glauben
ein rausch wäre per se wahnsinnig
versagen der rausch wie der traum
übrigens auch ist per se seri so
tierisch das heißt etwas was rein
innerlich stattfindet ja was ich liebe
dieses buch extrem denn nicht alles was
mir geschenkt hast du es gelang es geht
um die beschreibung von einer
gesellschaft die im rausch verfällt
roman mit kokain von mr gay es geht
wirklich darum dass auch hier ein mann
sein leben nicht anders auf die reihe
bringt als mit kokain das ist ja sehr
zeitgenössisch wie stehe ich zu diesem
argument dass es schriftsteller gegeben
hat für die die berauschung ein
notwendiges mittel warum überhaupt
stellt der deutsche sein das ist auch
ein großer mit das glaube ich eben auch
ich glaube viele von den trinkenden
schriftstellern auch schriftstellerinnen
übrigens haben als trotzdem geschafft
und nicht deswegen ich kann nicht
glauben dass wir hier sitzen und für
abstinenz plädieren ich es mit meiner
freundin nicolas steiner
das wird nie passieren nicola wird nie
ein buch schreiben ganz sicher dass
wochen teil ist mit diesem hoch und
heilig versprechen werden wir den
heutigen club
[Musik]